l'ia élève seule ses trois enfants
trouvés du travail c'est pour elle
mission impossible
elle est au chômage depuis sept ans
quelques contrats à durée déterminée
l'ont un peu sortie de chez elle
on lui a proposé un travail de
manutentionnaire à l'aéroport elle a dû
refuser pour les enfants à cause des
horaires en semaine ils mangent à la
cantine ça revient moins cher qui chante
du travail comme ça et pas manger à la
cantine sont habitués même si je me
présente à une place il faut pas que je
cours pour entrer les récupérant à
réunir on est beaucoup plus remplies
la famille vit avec environ 4500 francs
par mois les allocations familiales
l'un d'eux lui des chômages et l'aide au
logement pas de pension alimentaire mais
le père des filles rembourse le crédit à
la consommation qui l'avait pris
ensemble pour s'installer l'y a fait le
maximum pour ses enfants quand on a
trois enfants si on va travailler et
qu'il faut en plus payer quelqu'un pour
les faire garder servent énormément cher
c'est pas passé avec trois en france
pape et c'est donc ce n'est pas un choix
pour vous de rester au foyer
non c'est pas un choix c'est pas un
choix parce que arrivé à un moment donné
pour mort allemand et ben nous les
femmes je pense qu'on a besoin d'autre
chose que de rester à la maison
ce qu'on dit quand même compétition
monde et puis on est toujours toujours
avec les enfants donc être enfermé à la
maison constamment c'est pas pire ce
sont des va dévaloriser rapport aux
autres et le dit est ce que tu
préfèrerais que ta maman travaille
l'aîné michael à 12 ans il est moins
souvent à la maison
le collège et sport les copains même
s'il en est conscient le chômage de sa
mère ne le perturbe pas trop pour moi ça
change rien puisque je vais à l'école je
mange je pages et il a du fond et
habillez moi ça change rien mais monde
pour elle aussi pour elle songerait tout
elle tente de passer des concours pour
travailler si possible dans
l'administration c'est mieux pour les
horaires alors elle révise français
maths informatique un emploi ce serait
plus qu'un revenu mais c'est pas que
financièrement c'est moralement c'est le
contact avec les autres films ont dû
travailler les volets pinon reste en
arrière et puis le jour où on est on est
vraiment perdu la vie tourne autour de
ces enfants exclusivement autour d'eux
mais depuis trop longtemps
aujourd'hui elle voudrait sortir de chez
elle mais l'avenir
l'ua paraît bien bouché